please understand ladies and gentlemen  inflation makes the rich  extremely rich  the middle class will pay higher taxes  and the poor will get poor because  they're the ones who can't afford the 25  dollar wagu steak that my friends are  selling if you understand what's going  on the problem is the u.s dollar because  in 1944 it stopped being money or  stopped you know it just became the  reserve currency of the world and in 71  nixon took the dollar off the gold  standard  and so when kim and i wrote richard  porter 25 years ago today we said savers  are losing your house is not an asset  and so oh i bought a property what do  you think i can't even talk to him  because this to me is 2007 all over  again and this is where we are today